POI Dance Fusion is one of the most
exciting POI Innovations of the past
decade integrating POI with dance not
only recontextualizes many classic poy
tricks it also adds a new level of
musicality to PO spinning and
performance it can seem daunting to
navigate the challenges of learning both
sides of this equation and putting them
together in harmony so in this video I'm
offering up PO dance moves at five
different skill levels to help you find
the right challenge for where you are in
your flow Journey
Drex here from Drex Factor POI sharing
with you the love of Po spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and in this video I'm going to guide you
through po dance moves to fit several
different skill levels but before we
dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk flow fests flow
toys pyro Tera light toys and Ultra poy
for helping to make videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non- business friend of the channel
Becca beonin thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission po spinning has always had a
dance component to it but artists from
the past decade have been exploring this
in Greater depth than at any other point
in the props modern history the Arts
roots are in kapahaka of course the
ceremonial dances of the Maui people of
a aroa or New Zealand but the version of
Po that became popular in the Western
World differs significantly from it in
placing more emphasis on technicality
and virtuosity than on meaning ritual or
dance in the past decade po Spinners
like Ty roachford Zeus chova and yours
truly have been carving out a new
approach to POI that integrates elements
of a variety of different dance styles
into it and it does have to be said that
the styles of dance that we and the many
other po dancers out there have worked
with have been fairly unique to each
individual working in the field because
of that all the moves I'm presenting
here will also be unique to my style of
poy Dance Fusion and thus have a strong
contemporary modern and Jazz influence
rather than say hipop or ballet
influences that are more likely to be
found in Tai roachford or zuo shova
Styles but regardless of which style of
dance is best suited to you I'm hoping
you'll find something on this list that
will inspire ire you and make you
intrigued to learn more so let's dive in
level one beginner under curves and over
curves under curves and over curves are
a surprisingly simple way to add a lot
more visual appeal to many po tricks
that don't require you to learn any
fancy footwork the simple Act of bending
your knees in sequence to take your
pelvis around in a circle makes for a
surprisingly effective complement to a
wide variety of poi tricks the key here
is to seek out tricks that take the
hands and POI around around in together
same or split Time same direction but my
pick for the best option for beginners
is
windmills check out the difference
between a windmill with knees locked
versus performing these over and under
curves the difference is huge but the
utility of under curves and over curves
don't end there here's a small selection
of other po moves that work beautifully
with this concept at several different
skill levels try over curves and under
curves with tuck turns to emphasize
their circular path and Flow or with
fourbe fountains to intensify the
movement of the POI as they wrap around
your body under curves and over curves
even work with more advanced po moves
like hybrids that keep the hands and
together same check out this Tri ketra
versus pendulum both with and without
over curves and under curves with the
curves the trick seems to be performed
by the whole body you don't have to know
these more advanced tricks to make over
and under curves work however add them
to your toolbox early so you can use
them for countless tricks down the road
and speaking of P down the road our next
po dance move will start our feet moving
with some simple footwork that is
surprisingly versatile level two
beginner intermediate gads or step touch
I've used the term Gad to describe this
technique in the past but there's been
some disagreement from dancers in my
comment section as to whether this
footwork actually qualifies or not
regardless of whether it does or not it
absolutely does match a jazz technique
known as a step touch whether you call
it a glissade or a step touch this
footwork technique is is an effective
way to move a performer's body back and
forth across the stage while keeping the
hands focused more or less in a single
spot this technique is a great fit for
split time
butterflies
caps and stall Chasers but my pick for
the PO trick best suited to learning it
for beginner intermediate Spinners is
waist
wraps we generally think of waist straps
going from side to side across our
bodies as we stand still in one place
which makes it all the more interesting
visually when this Dynamic gets reversed
and it's our bodies that move instead
switch from forward to reverse weaves
and back again as you take these steps
back and forth from side to side and
you'll find that regardless of Direction
The Weave winds up isolated in space
it's a cool and unexpected effect that
gets a lot more mileage out of a py
trick we pick up fairly early on in our
po
Journeys you can even play with
switching back and forth between waist
straps as you stand in place to step
touches going back and forth to play
with how this py trick takes up space
around your body but not all forms of
dance technique require us to move our
feet there are plenty of techniques out
there that Center on non-traditional
ways to move our bodies like my next
pick level three intermediate pendulum
tutting tutting is an impressive dance
technique that arranges the performers
arms hands and sometimes other body
parts into right angles that shift and
rotate around each other
you'd think that with poise flexibility
it wouldn't be a great fit for creating
these sorts of angles but you'd be wrong
this is a technique I discovered a
couple years ago that involves combining
tutting with poy pendulums point
isolations and point isolation stalls we
can rotate our hands and forearms around
our elbows and use shorter poy to
complement the angles that our hands
form as they rotate through these
different
positions this can be challenging
because it requires us to find specific
positions with our hands and forearms in
coordination with the timing of our POI
pendulums if we're off by even a little
the POI keeps swinging and the effect is
lost this technique is a great fit for
intermediate Spinners both because it
teaches a great deal of precision in the
movement of the arms and hands but also
because the skills necessary to do clean
Point isolation stalls are incredibly
important to more advanced POI
techniques work on performing these
moves going back and forth across the
body as well as switching to split
timings for bonus points see what other
shapes you can create in between the
positions of your hand tutting and the
lines these moments can
create with these points covered it's
time for us to move on to POI dance
moves that are going to require us to
move in ways that are normally pretty
difficult for POI and also tend to be
goals for dancers too level four
intermediate Advanced floor rolls being
able to take a floor roll is one of
those challenges that really shows you
how well you're able to control your
momentum and body Center as you spin POI
dropping to the floor and coming back up
without the aid of your hands is no joke
while there are several methods for
performing floor work that many po
dancers have explored over the years
this is definitely the version that I
see performed most
often to perform it properly a dancer
must carefully lower themselves to the
ground on one knee transfer weight
across their pelvis to the other and
have enough momentum left in their head
to guide them back to standing this
technique can take a lot of practice
floor work is usually the bane of poi
spinning because we almost always have
our POI in our hands as we spin so all
of our techniques for getting to the
ground and back up must involve methods
that do not engage our hands that's
sometimes challenging for even
experienced dancers to do the poy trick
of choice for this technique is
definitely the cork screw because it
goes with the direction of the body
movement and keeps the POI out of the
way during the roll I've also seen this
performed with horizontal flowers to
mixed effect but the Cor screws have the
best presentation I've seen so far for
this technique so that's where I think
you should focus your attention so we've
moved our hips moved our feet tutted our
arms and taken the action down to the
floor for our last level I'm throwing a
doozy at you that even I still struggle
with level five Advanced
FES FES are considered a pretty Advanced
technique among even traditional dancers
so swinging around an object as you're
you're doing it is definitely a level
unto itself FES involve taking the
performer's body up to balance on the
toes of one leg while the other leg
whips around to pull the performer in a
complete turn they require an enormous
amount of control so much so that I
still have yet to get a good handle on
them as a dancer
myself the good news and bad news is
that the PO contribute to the momentum
of the turn making it easier to get
around this has the drawback of making
the PO more likely to throw you off
balance however so performing FAS with
the poy requires a lot more core
strength and
control foes with po have long been seen
as a painfully difficult challenge both
by people who started on PO as well as
classically trained dancers already
familiar with the technique so much so
that when I caught my first po fo on
video it was my dancer friends who
reacted with the greatest amount of
shock to it a variety of poy tricks can
accompany a fo from cork screws to
flowers but my favorite trick for this
task is a horizontal flower the POI
extending to the sides accentuates the
working leg as it whips around and makes
the trick feel symmetrical and
satisfying in a way that I really
appreciate and if you'd like to deepen
the knowledge you gain from this video
with some helpful drills and exercises
you should check out the flow Circle the
flow circle is an exclusive weekly
lesson available only to my patreon
subscribers this month I'm sharing
exercises designed to help you improve
your PO dance skills everything from
different footwork exercises to an
intensive on PO turns and pirouettes all
to get you moving and feeling confident
with the props sooner sign up over at
patreon.com Factor pooy the first lesson
is available now what did you think of
my list are there poy Dance Fusion
techniques you wish I'd added leave me a
comment and let me know be sure to like
comment share and subscribe to help
other people find this video and to help
my channel grow
[Music]
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I want to give a shout out to
my flow patrons that are listed up on
screen y'all rock thanks so much for
making this video and all the videos on
my channel possible and if you out there
watching aren't currently a supporter
but you still love the work that do I
would love to invite you to help me out
by checking out my patreon over at
patreon.com factor pooy and signing up
if you like what you see I've got a
whole host of awesome rewards available
but more important than that you'll be
supporting my mission to bring po
spinning and flow Arts to the whole wide
world so go check that out please and
thank you interested in picking up more
poy Dance Fusion moves recently I
uploaded a video detailing my favorite
po dance moves for beginners and I'll
link to to it down in the description as
well as up on screen be sure to check
that out for more inspiration in the
meantime thanks so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow your Sals
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon take care now peace